- Es ist wirklich unglaublich, was du
geschafft hast!
- Ich weiß doch noch gar nicht, ob ich
die Prüfung bestanden habe.
- Ich bin überzeugt,
dass du bestanden hast.
- Hoffentlich reicht's.
Ich bin mir wegen des Briefs, den
ich schreiben musste, nicht sicher.
Und ich habe Angst, dass ich im
schriftlichen Teil meines Tests
zu viele Fehler gemacht habe.
- Du wirst wegen ein paar Fehlern
schon nicht durchfallen.
Du musst dir keine Sorgen machen.
- Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es schaffe,
mir keine Sorgen zu machen.
- Noch drei Gläser davon und
das Problem ist gelöst.
- Und bald beginnt dann deine Ausbildung.
Da wirst du noch viele Prüfungen
machen müssen.
- Stimmt. Und ich bin gespannt auf
alles, was jetzt kommt.
- Diese Prüfung ist der erste Schritt
auf deinem neuen Weg.
Auf Nicos Weg!
- Auf Nicos Weg!